Bitte schön.
Okay.
Okay. Guten Abend.
Guten Abend.
Mein Name ist Mechtafmatt.
Ich bin heute hier den Sabende Assistentin.
Ich würde gerne mit Ihnen das Aufnahmegespräch durchführen.
Ist das okay für Sie?
Ja, ja, Hauptsache, jemand hilft mir überhaupt.
Okay. Wie heißen Sie?
Ich heiße Martin Müller.
Könnten Sie bitte Ihre Vor- und Nachname langsam bestabieren?
Ja, der Vorname ist Martin.
M-A-R-T-I-N.
Ja.
Und der Familienname ist Müller.
M-E-L-L-E-R.
Okay, Herr Müller.
Wie alt sind Sie?
Ja, ich bin schon 87.
Okay.
Und wie groß und wie schwer sind Sie?
Ja, ich wiege nur noch so 60 Kilo.
Es ist nicht mehr viel 3.
Und ich bin 165.
165 Kilo.
Wie kann ich Ihnen helfen?
Ich habe euch alles gesehen.
Ja, wissen Sie, ich bin heute in der Früh,
als ich ins Badezimmer gegangen bin,
und ich habe mich auf die Toilette gewollt.
Da bin ich gestürzt.
Dann habe ich mich mit einmal auf dem Busboden wieder gefunden.
Im Badezimmer.
Ich bin dann schnell wieder in mein Bett zurück.
Und so gut es ging.
Und jetzt sind aber die Schmerzen auf der rechten Seite immer schlimmer geworden.
Und dann habe ich meinen Sohn angerufen und gesagt,
hör mal, du musst mal kommen und musst mich mal zur Klinik bringen.
Ich habe solche tollen Schmerzen.
Okay, wo haben Sie genau die Schmerzen?
Ja, so im rechten Oberschenkel, so in der Hüfte.
Und das strahlt eigentlich auch so bis in den Oberchenkel Richtung Knie rein.
Und es sind jetzt inzwischen schon sehr starke Schmerzen.
Als ich so lange im Bett war, ging es noch.
Aber als ich dann versucht habe, aufzustehen, habe ich gemerkt,
ich kann überhaupt gar nicht auftreten auf dem Bein.
Ja, das heißt, Sie können nicht laufen, oder?
Ich kann gar nicht laufen.
Nein, nein, mein Sohn hat mich mühsam ins Auto verfrachtet.
Und hier im Krankenhaus haben wir dann gleich ein Rollstuhl geholt.
Und dann hat er mich hierher gebracht.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Und hatten Sie unmächtig?
Oder wie passiert diesen Unfall?
Ja, ich kann das gar nicht so genau sagen.
Also ich weiß sicher, dass ich mir ordentlich schwindelig war.
Ja, aber ob ich tatsächlich unmächtig war,
mit einmal habe ich da unten gelegen.
Habe ich richtig verstanden?
Sie haben selbstbewusst Verlust, oder?
Sie hatten beim Unfall.
Ich kann es nicht genau sagen.
Ich weiß nicht, wie lange ich da so gelegen habe,
ob ich überhaupt unmächtig war oder nicht.
Ich glaube eigentlich, dass ich da nicht lange gelegen habe.
Aber ich weiß es nicht sicher.
Ich habe nicht auf die Uhr geguckt, als ich losgegangen bin.
Und mit einmal lag ich halt da.
Und dann habe ich gemerkt, dass es halt wegtut.
Und bin ich in mein Bett zurückgegangen.
Und jetzt haben Sie recht oberschenke,
besonders hüftes Schmerzen.
Und haben Sie schwindeln?
Bitte?
Haben Sie auch schwindeln?
Ja, jetzt nicht mehr.
Nicht mehr.
Nein, ich bewege mich ja auch gar nicht.
Okay.
Und ist Ihnen Rötung, Schwellung oder Überwärmung
an der betroffene Stelle aufgefallen?
Ich habe da nicht so genau hingeguckt.
Ich nehme schon an, dass das irgendwie ein bisschen geschwollen ist.
Also es tut jedenfalls ordentlich weh.
Ja, bestimmt ist das irgendwie ein bisschen blau.
Aber wie gesagt, ich kann da nicht so gut hingucken.
Okay.
Und haben Sie blaufebliche Veränderung der Haut bemerkt an der Stelle?
Wie gesagt, ich kann das nicht so genau angucken,
weil ich mich so schlecht bewegen kann.
Das mussten Sie dann gleich mal gucken.
Ja, ja, ja.
Ich kann bei der köpferlichen Unterhälfte schauen.
Und spülen Sie gleich.
Beide Beine?
Nee, also ich habe tatsächlich das Gefühl,
dass dieses rechte Bein, dass das so ein bisschen,
ja, ein bisschen kribbelt.
Und...
Das ist ein Taubreizgefühl, haben Sie Taubreizgefühl?
Ja, das fühlt sich so ein bisschen,
das fühlt sich ein bisschen komisch an.
Und ich habe auch das Gefühl,
dass ich das gar nicht selber bewegen kann.
Und Sie haben schon Erwärm, Sie hatten Schwindeling
und welche Form könnten Sie bitte genau beschreiben,
Drehung oder Schwankerl?
Ich hatte das Gefühl, dass sich alles dreht, genau.
Noch?
Ja.
Sie haben gar nicht Schwankerl.
Okay.
Und es ist, irgendwelche Schmerzen auch andere
Körperteile oder...
Ja, die Hauptsache ist eigentlich,
dass da diese Hüfte so wehtut,
vielleicht so ein bisschen am Arm,
aber im Vergleich ist es nicht schlimm.
Oder Bewegungs-Einstränkungen?
Nee, das kann ich alles bewegen.
Okay, okay, das ist auch wichtig.
Ja, okay.
Haben Sie Fieber?
Ich habe mich gemessen, aber ich glaube nicht,
dass ich Fieber habe.
Okay.
Haben Sie Atemnot oder Herz-Rasen, Herzklopfen?
Nein, also, als ich gemerkt habe,
dass ich da unten liegt,
habe ich wahrscheinlich ein bisschen Herzklopfen gehabt.
Ja, aber ich habe jetzt nicht das Gefühl,
dass ich irgendwie ein Herzproblem habe.
Normalerweise leiden Sie an Herzkrankheiten?
Ja, ich habe natürlich in meinem Alter,
können Sie sich vorstellen,
dass mein Herz nicht mehr so gut funktioniert.
Haben Sie Probleme bei Wasserlassen oder Schulgang?
Ja, bei Wasserlassen habe ich natürlich
schon so meine Probleme in meinem Alter.
Aber eigentlich sonst,
Schulgang funktioniert ganz gut.
Okay, welche Probleme haben Sie bei Wasserlassen?
Ja, dass ich eben manchmal ziemlich oft gehen muss
und dass es auch manchmal nicht so richtig
mehr einen guten Strahl gibt,
sondern so ein bisschen tröpfelt.
Aber guck mal auf mein Geburtsdatum.
Ja, ja, okay.
Und haben Sie Schlafstorungen?
Ja, wie gesagt, ich muss halt nachts immer mal
auf die Toilette.
Und ja, manchmal habe ich das auch so,
dass ich nachts ein bisschen Herzprobleme habe.
Dann muss ich das Bett ein bisschen hochstellen.
Aber normalerweise kann ich eigentlich ganz gut schlafen.
Und wie oft oder wie viel mal
müssen Sie auch für die Toilette gehen?
Nachts, ich meine.
Zwei Mal ungefähr.
Und wie viel Kistel benutzt du?
Sie zum Schlafen?
Normalerweise ein.
Aber ich kann mal ein Bett so ein bisschen verstellen.
Und manchmal, wenn ich das Gefühl habe,
mir geht es nicht so gut,
dann kann ich das so ein bisschen hochstellen.
Okay, okay.
Und haben Sie irgendwelche krönchen Krankheiten?
Ja, ich habe natürlich meine Hochdruck.
Natürlich, jede Menge,
wissen Sie in meinem Alter.
Also ich habe natürlich hohen Blutdruck,
aber schon seit 30 Jahren.
Seit 30 Jahren.
Ja, ja, ja.
Und ich habe auch so ne chronische Bruntitis.
Ja, auch das lässt mich manchmal nachts nicht so gut schlafen.
Ja, ja.
Dann muss ich halt nachts mal husten oder so.
Und seit wann haben Sie chronische Bruntitis?
Ja, so festgestellt hat man das vor drei Jahren,
aber vielleicht habe ich das auch schon länger.
Okay.
Ja, und mit meinem Herzen,
das ist halt ein altes Herz.
Ja, das ist nicht mehr so leistungsfähig.
Das hat mir mein Arzt auch gesagt,
ja, mein Alter ist so ein Herz nicht gemacht.
Okay.
Und welche Herzkrankheiten wurde diagnostiziert?
Wissen Sie, wer es ist?
Ich weiß nicht, wie das heißt.
Ja, ich denke mal, dass das sowas ist, ja.
Mhm.
Aber ich habe jedenfalls noch keinen Herz in Farb gehabt.
Okay, gut.
Ja, und seit wann haben Sie Herzprobleme?
Ach, schon 20 Jahre.
Okay.
Und welche Medikamente nehmen Sie regelmäßig ein?
Also ich nehme regelmäßig aspirin,
also 100 diese morgen zu einem,
dann nehme ich Omeprazol
und dann nehme ich noch Metaprolol.
Omeprazol ist 20 mg, oder?
Ja, ich glaube, das steht 40 drauf.
40, okay.
Ja, einmal, morgens.
Auch einmal, ja.
Okay.
Aspirin 100 mg, Omeprazol 40 mg, und was noch?
Dann nehme ich noch Metaprolol.
Metaprolol, okay.
Dann nehme ich morgen und abends.
Und die Dosierung, puh, weiß ich gar nicht.
Okay.
Und Sie haben schon elbend Atelier,
Blutdruck, Hochblutdruck und Brunsche Brunschtes
und Herzschweche und was noch?
Leiden Sie?
Ja, ich habe auch ein bisschen Osteoporose.
Das habe ich auch schon vor langer Zeit festgestellt.
Und dann hatte ich auch mal,
habe ich auch ein bisschen
niedrige Schildrösenleistung.
Okay.
Und was nehmen Sie gegen niedrige Schildrösen?
Ja, dann nehme ich Zuroxin.
Welche Dosierung?
Oh, das weiß ich gar nicht.
Ich nehme da morgens eine Tablette.
Okay.
Und gegen Osteoporose nehmen Sie etwas ein.
Dann nehme ich eigentlich nichts ein.
Kasium, Magnesium oder?
Nein, ich versuche halt, viel Milch zu trinken
und Käse zu essen.
Aber Medikamente nehme ich da nicht.
Okay.
Ich würde gerne wissen, ob Sie Blut im Urin bemerkt haben.
Seid der Unfall.
Hab ich jetzt nicht so genau geguckt,
ob ich das nicht gesehen habe.
Ich habe es nicht gesehen.
Ich glaube nicht.
Okay.
Und würde ich dann schon mal operieren?
Ja, ich habe schon mal die Krampfadern operiert bekommen.
Und dann hatte ich mal hier an der rechten Wange,
hatte ich so eine Hautveränderung,
die man wegoperiert hat.
Wann haben Sie wegen der Varizan operiert?
Oh, das ist schon lange, lange her.
Da war ich noch ein junger Mann.
Das ist schon 30 Jahre her.
Okay.
Und Sie haben schon erwähnt,
Sie wurden auch wegen Hautveränderungen operiert.
Sie haben schon erwähnt,
Und welche Diagnose wurde festgestellt?
Ja, man hat da etwas gesagt.
Ich gebe so etwas ein Basal.
Basal, die Uhr.
Irgendwie so etwas.
So hieß das, glaube ich.
Mhm.
Und wann war das?
Oh, das ist jetzt schon lange her.
Mehr als 10 Jahre.
Ich denke, so 15 Jahre wahrscheinlich her.
Okay.
Ja.
Ja, ich habe nie geraucht.
Mhm.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Hoch ja, so hin und wieder trinke ich gerne mal ein Gläschen Sekt.
Oder so eine kleine Flasche, so ein Piccolo.
Ist das gut für den Kreislauf?
Ja, so.
Ich würde mal sagen, Gläschen Sekt 2, 3 Mal in der Woche.
Mhm.
2, 3 Mal ein Gläschen Sekt.
Pro Woche.
Und was noch?
Sonst eigentlich nichts, weil es schmeckt mir nicht mehr so gut.
Okay, okay.
Und nehmen Sie sonstige Drogen ein?
Drogen?
Ne, so ein neumotischen Kram, das habe ich nichts mit zu tun.
Okay.
Haben Sie irgendwelche Allergien oder Unverträglichkeit?
So viel ich weiß nicht.
Aber halt doch, ich habe irgendwann mal Penicillin bekommen.
Und das habe ich nicht vertragen.
Und da hat man mir gesagt, ich soll das nicht wieder nehmen.
Aber ich habe das auch seither nicht wiedergenommen.
Das ist so wichtig.
Und wie reagieren Sie auf Penicillin?
Das ist schon so lange her.
Ich weiß das gar nicht mehr genau.
Ich meinte, es war irgendwie so,
dass mein Gesicht so gerötet war.
Und irgendwie ging es mir dann direkt danach gar nicht gut.
Und haben Sie noch falset dabei?
Nein.
Ich habe das ja nie wieder genommen.
Und ich weiß nicht, dass ich da allergisch bin.
Okay, treiben Sie Sportregen, Missich?
Früher mal, lange, lange Zeit habe ich mal ein bisschen Sport gemacht.
Aber jetzt in meinem Alter mache ich keinen Sport mehr.
Da ist das schon Sport, wenn ich meine Treppe hoch und runter gehen muss.
Sind Sie vorständig geimpft?
Ja, was man so braucht.
Ich habe eine Corona-Impfung, habe ich alle Intermediate.
Und Tetanus, wann war der letzte Tetanus-Impfung?
Das muss schon lange her sein.
Ich bin ja nicht mehr im gefährlichen Bereich.
Was soll mir schon passieren?
Vor langer, langer Zeit habe ich meine Impfung bekommen.
Da habe ich im Garten gearbeitet und habe mich ein bisschen verletzt.
Da habe ich mal eine bekommen, das ist schon sehr lange her.
Okay, in den letzten zehn Jahren hatten Sie Tetanus-Impfung?
Bestimmt nicht.
Nicht?
Und gibt es irgendwie...
Natürlich nicht immer zur Grippe-Impfung, da sagt man,
alte Leute sollen das machen.
Ja, das ist so wichtig.
Sie haben chronische Branche und das ist so wichtig.
Und gibt es irgendwelche chronische Krankheiten in Ihrer Familie?
Hm, ich wusste gar nicht.
Das ist schon lange her.
Ich weiß nicht, warum ich das so lange habe.
Das ist so eine lange Zeit.
Also mein Bruder hatte irgendwie eine Hirnblutung,
aber das ist ja keine chronische Erkraufe.
Das ist so ein Notfall gewesen.
Also mein Eltern, das ist ja so lange her,
ich weiß nicht, woran die gestorben sind.
Das ist ja schon Ewigkeiten zurück.
Okay, okay.
Herr Müller, Sie sind in Rente,
aber welchen Beruf haben Sie geübt?
Ich war Angestellter bei der Handrax-Kammer.
Hm, hm.
Und haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, wie gesagt, mein Sohn und dann habe ich noch zwei Töchter.
Entschuldigung, insgesamt drei Kinder?
Ein Sohn und zwei Töchter.
Okay, sind Ihre Kinder gesund?
Ja, natürlich.
Klar, so viel ich weiß.
Klar haben Sie immer mal irgendwas, aber grundsätzlich sind Sie gesund.
Leben Sie mit Ihrer Frau oder Kinder?
Leider verwirrt wird, ja.
Aber ich lebe alleine.
Die Kinder sind zwar nicht so weit weg,
die sind alle hier in der Stadt,
aber ich wohne in meiner Wohnung alleine.
Seit ist es vorbei.
Okay, und fertig.
Nicht fertig.
Ja, das müsste ich mir am Ende.
Ein paar Fragen.
Ja, haben Kollegen oder Kolleginnen noch andere Fragen?
Ich glaube, sehr vollständig gefragt.
Welche Fragen habe ich nicht gestohnt?
Die Lechlerin unseres Kollegen ist auch hier.
Vielleicht war ein Moment schade.
Vielleicht war sie deshalb ein bisschen aufgeregt.
Aber war auch gut.
Also, was fehlt?
Was fehlt?
Ich möchte noch etwas wissen.
Wie kann ich uns schade?
Wie stark Ihre Schmerzen auf die Skala...
Ja, das stimmt, das hat sie nicht gefragt, genau.
Aber Sie machen event sehr stark.
Genau.
Also, es gibt an 7 bis 8 von 10,
weil Bewegung und in Ruhe kann das aushalten,
da ist es 3 bis 4 von 10.
Und was Sie auch nicht gefragt haben,
ob ich Tabletten eingenommen habe dagegen, ne?
Ja, und Schmerzbeschreibung.
So, ja.
Hab ich gesagt?
Ich habe gesagt, Stechen der Schmerz.
Stechen der Schmerz in der rechten Hüfte.
Und strahlt aus.
Hab ich geschildert.
Und schade, noch andere Fragen?
Nein.
Noch andere Fragen, Kollegen.
Geboren ist nicht gefragt.
Der Geburtstag ist nicht erfragt.
Ja, das stimmt.
Also, das ist insofern eigentlich nur wichtig,
weil es eine Hürde ist,
dass man die Zahlen drehen macht.
Weil die deutschen Zahlen schwierig sind.
Ist das Geburtstag und manchmal eine Hürde,
dass man irgendwie sich vertut.
Aber genau genommen,
wenn man mal den richtigen Originalfall sich vorstellt,
wie es im Krankenhaus wäre,
Sie haben immer irgendein Etikett
oder eine Karteikarte oder ein Computerbildschirm,
wo Sie die Daten haben.
Und wenn der ist 87 Jahre alt
und dann sehen Sie, der ist Jahrgang 37,
dann stimmt das ja.
Ja, das geht aber.
Unsere Simulation ist hier.
Müssen wir geboren?
Müssen wir fragen.
Auch die Schwaben wollen das haben.
Die warten auf.
Der Patient schildert eine Syncope.
Deswegen müssen wir endische Beschwerden
eine Frage gestalten.
Hatten Sie früher endische Beschwerden?
Oder kann man schon einmal ohnmächtig sein?
Ja.
Und wir haben gefragt,
welche Sekunde, dauer und seit,
wir haben gestellt,
aber der Patient hat nicht gewusst.
Er hat nicht geantwortet.
Aber endische Beschwerden müssen wir stellen.
Ich wollte wissen,
ob Sie ohnmächtig waren
oder nicht.
Deswegen habe ich noch mal gefragt.
Aber der Patient hat gesagt, ich weiß nicht.
Ja, ja.
Wenn man ohnmächtig ist,
ist man ja nicht überweist.
Er hat gemerkt,
er ist schwindelig,
hat es hingefallen
und er hat gemerkt,
ich liege auf dem Boden.
Wahrscheinlich war er kurzohnmächtig,
aber wir wissen das nicht.
Er kann selber keine Angaben machen.
Und da er alleine lebt, haben wir keine Infos.
Der Patient hat ein gutes Schilder.
Aber der Patient hat gesagt,
dass er Takyokardi habe.
Und eine Vorerkrankung
hat eine Ausgabe.
Deswegen müssen wir
eine Attrarchibulation fragen.
Weil der Patient
eine Sinkopiert hat
und deswegen gibt es
eine Emboli.
Deswegen müssen wir
fragen.
Wo ich mir nicht sicher war,
müsste man bei einem solchen Patientin sagen,
wir unterbrechen jetzt mal kurz
und machen mal eben ein EKG
und überprüfen Vitalparameter.
Das würde ich vielleicht vorschlagen
für jemanden, der in dem Alter ist.
Wo man davon ausgehen muss,
dass der Zwischenfall hatte,
der zu der Verletzung geführt hat.
Das wäre das einzige,
wo ich sagen würde,
da hätte man vielleicht
vorher intervenieren müssen.
Wobei das wahrscheinlich auch wieder von Prüfer
zu Prüfer verschieden ist, die einen sagen so,
die anderen so.
Aber von meinem
Gefühl her und Sachverstand würde ich sagen,
es wäre schon schlau,
diesen Patienten kurz zu checken,
bevor man da weiter befragt.
Das sind meine Fragen.
Können wir
Arsatzgeschef anfangen?
Von mir aus immer.
Vielen Dank.
Guten Abend Frau
Dr. Wichmann.
Ich würde gerne heute
über
Martin Müller berichten.
Haben Sie kurz Zeit?
Was ist denn mit dem Patienten?
Herr Müller ist 87 Jahre alt.
60 kg schwer
und 1,65 m
groß.
Der Patient hat
gehabt an,
dass er morgens früh
im Badestimmer gestürzt ist
und gestürzt sei.
Er hat sich
auf der rechten Seite gestürzt.
Auf der rechten Seite
hat er
stark geschmatzten
im rechten Oberschenkel
besonders in der Hüfte.
Die Schmerzstrahlung
in den rechten Oberschenkel
bis zum Knie
aus.
Er sagte,
er könne nicht richtig laufen.
Deswegen hat er
sonnen im Krankenhaus geliefert.
Sein Sohn?
Ja.
Der Patient erwähnt
er hat
im Badest
morgens früh
vertigo
drehen
Charakterartig vertigo
und
beschreibt auch Sinkof
ich habe noch einmal gefragt
und er hat gesagt,
er kann
nicht erinnern.
Nicht richtig, nicht ganz vollständig erinnern.
Und
außerdem klagte er
über Paristäse und Hypostasy
an der Stelle
und
er hat auch im
Morgen früh
vertreibte er
Parpitations
und
er hat keine
vertigo und Parpitations.
Er hat auch im Morgen früh
noch ein Parpitations.
Er hat eine vertigo und Parpitations.
Als Vorerkrankung
leide er unter
Arteriealhypertomie seit 30 Jahren.
Seit drei Jahren
leide er COPD.
Seit 20 Jahren
leide er an Herzinsuffizienz.
Seit sehr lange
weiß ich nicht genau,
Osteporose und Hypothrose.
Ja,
nehme legermäßig
Aspirin 100 mg morgens
Omeprazole 40 mg morgens
und Metoprolol dosoring unbekannt
morgens abends und Tiroxin morgens
und wurde
wegen der Varisen vor 30 Jahren
und wegen der
Basilium vor 15 Jahren operiert.
Und er ist nicht raucher.
Er trinkt 2-3 Mal
ein Glas Sicht
und keine Drogenkonsum.
Er hat Pestidienalläge
und
darauf reagiert
er mit Flaschung am Gesicht
und
er trabt keinen Sport
und er ist vollständig geimpft.
Aber er hat gesagt,
in den letzten 10 Jahren
hat er keine Tetanusimpfung.
Und in der Formatik
und in der Familienanamnese
sein Bruder
hatte
er weiß nicht
Hemblutung
und er war angestellte
er hat 2 Kinder und verwittet
und erlebt alleine.
Und die Symptome
deuten am ehesten auf
Femmuchalffraktur hin
oberschenkel-heißfraktur hin
oder was könnte es differenzialdiagnose sein?
Ja, als differenzialdiagnose
pathologische fraktur,
multifraktur, oberschenkelfraktur
kann sein
oder perlvisfraktur
kann sein.
Was machen Sie mit den Patienten?
Ja, zuerst
würde ich den Patienten
körperliche untersuchen.
Worauf achten Sie bei den körperlichen Untersuchungen?
Ja, worauf?
Ich würde gerne
Bewegungseinschränkungen
und auch
ich muss auf akut
Battentrauma
auch abdomentrauma
mit
perlvisfraktur
könnte sein auch
eine abdominal Trauma
und
eine
schwingbare
Absichtung.
Was machen Sie bei der ersten Inspektion?
Ja, Femmaturen.
Farbeveränderung der Haut
und Puls auch wichtig.
Was wäre möglicherweise
eine Position?
Ja, die
extremität
verhalten
ist auch wichtig.
Ja, genau.
Eine Fehlstellung potentiell.
Wichtigste ist
wildgebende Verfahren.
Ich würde gerne so erst
einen Grundkern
beides.
Beides Seite
verrennen.
Die Abdominalsonographie
würde gerne auch durchführen.
Um die akute Abdomine
oder andere Nevenorganen
Verletzungen auszuschließen.
Gut, okay.
Ja.
Sorry.
Ja, ich muss mal überlegen.
Ich würde gerne die Blutabnahme veranlasen.
Und Koalitionsparameter und Blutgruppe für die Operation.
Blutgruppe.
Genau.
Und sehr gut.
Ja, gegen eine Beimelderfoperation.
Ja, und Blutbild.
Und andere Nierenwerte, lieberwerte auch.
Ausgrund des Alters wahrscheinlich, ne?
Ja, wegen des Alters.
Und benötigen wir auch Kontrastmittel verabreichen.
Und auch das ist wichtig, Nierenwerte.
Ja, natürlich.
Ja, gut.
Okay, ja, dann bin ich gespannt, welche Ergebnisse sie rausbekommen.
Es ist ja sehr wahrscheinlich, dass sie richtig liegen mit ihrer Diagnose.
Aber wir schauen uns das nachher genau an.
Wir gucken uns den Patienten nachher auf der Station zusammen an.
Ja, natürlich müssen wir so als Stationer aufnehmen.
Genau.
Ja.
Okay, danke.
Aber am Anfang diese Schreiben,
Herr Müller, kam heute Morgen wegen Schmerzen im rechten Koksa
und Peldic Bereich in Folge einer Syncope von unbekannten Dauer
im Badet Morg und anschließend einem Schüttersunst.
Lieber Dr. Günthes, nicht alle schreiben oder denken Druckreif.
Die Kollegin musste es ja erzählen.
Sie musste es ja vortragen.
Da kann man vielleicht nicht so einen komplexen Zusammenhang.
Man kann das auch nacheinander erklären.
Das ist die sichere Bank, weil sie auf die Art und Weise
richtige Sätze konstruieren.
Wenn sie so einen komplexen Satz machen, in dem so viele Vents
und Arves drin sind, dann haben sie am Ende den Faden verloren
und auch die Gruffer verlieren den Faden.
Sie haben das nicht richtig vor sich.
Ich fand es gar nicht schlecht.
Ihre Kollegin hat das zwar so ein bisschen
praktisch formuliert.
Ich habe das nicht mehr im Wort laut,
aber da kam zu uns mit starken Schmerzen
und dann hat sie die Vorgeschichte erklärt.
Aber eigentlich hat sie den Unfall hergegangen
und die Rahmenbedingungen finde ich ganz gut erklärt.
Abonni muslimyen medizinische Wörter, Benutsun.
Koksa, Pelvikberan.
Rechten zayte, rechten lateral zayte.
Ein bisschen medizinischer Wörter.
Koksa geht extra, steht hier bei mir auch.
Ja klar.
Es ist auch ein bisschen prüferabhängig,
wie stark die auf die Fachtherminologie abfahren.
Die einen machen es, die anderen nicht.
Ich weiß, die Düsseldorfer sind da ganz verrückt.
Ich weiß nicht, wie akademisch die Freiburger drauf sind.
Ja, zum Beispiel bei der Freiburg-Eisdeckammer
muss man nicht Geburtsdatum fragen.
Nur alte, wichtigste ist alte.
Geburtsdatum ist nicht unnötig.
Natürlich, man muss versuchen, Fachbegriffe zu verwenden,
aber vielleicht nicht immer nicht alles.
Das ist schwierig, vielleicht sofort übersetzen.
Wichtig ist eigentlich, dass sie richtige Sätze formulieren,
in denen auf allen Fälle die entscheidenden Informationen
rüberkommen.
Wenn Ihnen das gelingt, da die Fachtherminologie unterzubringen,
wunderbar.
Aber ich denke, Sie haben schon relativ sehr weitgehend,
zum Beispiel haben Sie über vertigo gesprochen,
Sie haben über...
Ich denke schon, dass da ziemlich viel Fachtherminologie schon...
Auf eine Fachfraktion.
Ja, aber...
Was mir aufgefallen ist,
weil das so eine Zeitangabe ist, die missverständlich war.
Sie haben gesagt, der Patient ist morgen früh, gestürzt oder was auch immer.
Am Morgen, oder früh am Morgen, das ist was anderes.
Morgen früh ist eigentlich Morgen, also heute ist Donnerstag,
dann ist Morgen Freitag, Morgen früh.
Das könnte Ihnen jemand vielleicht krumm nehmen,
wenn Sie den Zeitbegriff nicht so ganz gut drauf haben.
Das haben Sie zweimal gemacht.
Ja, ich habe nicht mehr mal, Kira.
Also am frühen Morgen, oder heute Morgen.
Heute Morgen, ja, ja.
Heute am frühen Morgen, das kann man sagen.
Dann haben Sie den Patienten was gefragt.
Ich habe mir das gleich aufgeschrieben.
Hatten Sie unmächtig?
Waren Sie unmächtig?
Ja, genau.
Das sind so kleine sprachliche Klippen.
Das schleicht sich immer etwas ein.
Aber ich denke mal, die Perfektion ist auch nicht unbedingt das Non-Plus-Ultra.
Man muss nicht alles perfekt machen.
Sie konnten sich mit dem Patienten, mit diesem alten Mann,
konnten sie sich gut verständigen.
Der war ja auch nicht so ganz einfach.
Der hat dann immer gesagt, ja, auch in meinem Alter,
und wissen sie schon und so.
Und der hat das immer so ein bisschen weggewischt, die Fragen.
Und letztendlich war er aber erstaunlich gut informiert,
muss man ja auch sagen.
Er kannte seine Tabletten.
Er weiß nicht jeder mit 87.
Das könnte Ihnen auch passieren, dass er sagt,
ich nehme eine kleine Weiße und dann habe ich noch so eine Grüne.
Dann habe ich noch eine, die muss ich einmal durchbrechen.
Gut, dann sind sie auch nicht viel schlauer als vor.
Der wusste eigentlich ganz gut Bescheid.
Er hatte vielleicht seinen Zettel mit, keine Ahnung.
Er hat ja auch eigentlich ganz gut geschildert,
wie der Unfall war.
Das könnte ja auch schlechter sein.
Aber ich finde, sie haben den gut angenommen
und gut mit ihm das Gespräch geführt.
Und sie haben auch sehr vollständig die Sachen wiedergegeben
gegenüber der Oberärztin.
Was mir so ein bisschen unklar war,
bei der Familie in einer Mese haben sie gesagt,
der Bruder hatte eine Hirnblutung.
Er weiß nicht so genau Bescheid,
aber der Patient gibt an,
dass sein Bruder eine Hirnblutung erlitten hat,
könnte man sagen.
Über die Eltern weiß er nichts,
weil das eben schon viele Jahre zurücklicht.
Ist ja auch nicht erstaunlich.
Gut.
Was ich hier von der letzten Simulation noch finde gerade,
was Sie tatsächlich nicht gefragt haben,
wann der Patient seine letzte Mahlzeit eingenommen hat.
Das wäre im Fall, dass eine Operation notwendig ist.
Natürlich noch eine relativ wichtige Information.
Es fällt mir jetzt aber ein,
wo ich das hier auf dem Zettel zu sehen sehe.
Gut.
Ich habe eine Frage.
Der Patient hat syncopiert oder der Patient ist syncopiert?
Welches ist wichtig?
Hatte Syncop ist syncopiert.
Würde ich auch sagen.
Hatte Syncop?
Ja.
Und ist syncopiert?
Ja, würde ich auch sagen.
Ich habe es nicht gelesen, syncopiert.
Ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher.
Ich müsste tatsächlich nachgucken.
Als Verb ist es mir nicht geläufig.
Und syncopieren.
Ich würde am ersten Tag.
Ich kann mir oft verrennen.
Ja.
Eigentlich ist es ja,
eigentlich ist es gut.
Ich habe es nicht gelesen, syncopiert.
Aber er hat es nicht gelesen.
Ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher.
Ich müsste tatsächlich nachgucken.
Eigentlich ist es keine,
ist ja nichts,
ist ja nichts, was man bewusst macht und tut.
Ich habe gesehen,
aber ich bin eingeschlagen.
Also, er ist,
würde eher sagen, er ist syncopiert.
Aber ich bin mir nicht mehr syncopiert.
Fragen Sie die Deutschlehrerin.
Ich mache Stefanie.
Okay, danke schön.
Ja, also ich, wie gesagt, Doktor Gündiz,
ich würde mich schuldig bleiben, die Antwort.
Aber ich würde so vom Gefühl sagen ist,
ich syncopiere.
Ja.
Ich denke, nicht.